les chars d'assaut et le pdg de
l'association québécoise de la
quincaillerie et des matériaux de
construction bonsoir mon ses ambitions
vous proposé de servir le québec d'abord
avant d'exporter aux états unis
expliquez-nous votre proposition
en fait la première raison c'est parce
qu'on est au départ sur les blocs de
départ d'une relance économique et c'est
beaucoup à base de construction de
bâtiments que le gouvernement et le
secteur privé veulent veulent se sortir
de cette pandémie dont il ya déjà un
manque de matériaux mais on pense que ça
va aller en croissant à en raison de la
volonté de d'encourager cette industrie
alors le prix est en hausse puisque
quand il ya un manque de matériaux
souvent il ya comme intérêt à ce que
certaines personnes puissent en profiter
pour y aller avec des prix assez fort
alors on dit en construction que trop
fort qu'à spa c'est une expression
québécoise du terroir mais je pense que
trop cher pourrait casser et nombre de
deux chantiers privés mais aussi
peut-être institutionnel est ce qu'on
peut faire chez vous chez nous vont
peut-être être reportée si les prix ne
sont plus contrôlés alors comment on
favorise le bois québécois et le bois au
québec et servir le québec tout en
respectant nos accords commerciaux avec
les états unis et avec l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
oui bah en fait la promotion de l'achat
local n'a rien à voir avec les règles
internationales
si moi j'achète à la boutique de la rue
saint denis qui on donne un coupon
rabais de 50 $ parce que j'encourage mon
commerce ça relève de la ville j'en ai
profité moyen de ce genre de programme
si on le pousse à l'échelle du québec
pour le secteur comme celui du bois on
pourrait facilement à partir d'une
mesure votée au conseil du trésor
proposer aux consommateurs et aux
entrepreneurs en construction qui
privilégie le bois québécois dans leurs
projets des avantages fiscaux des rabais
quoi que ce soit on ne touche pas du
tout aux règles internationales
quand on fait ça ok j'ai le parfait sa
demande vérification quand même jeu
je me demande jusqu'à quel point le
gouvernement peut détourner du bois par
exemple qui serait lui qui serait
destinée à l'exportation pour répondre
aux besoins du marché américain en
favorisant le marché québécois
je pense pas qu'il s'agit de détourner
il s'agit d'encourager tous les
partenaires toutes les parties prenantes
de celui qui coop l'arbre jusqu'à celui
qui va évoluer a installé son départ
quatre à la maison à faire preuve de
solidarité
donc ce n'est pas d'enlever à l'autre
c'est juste de dire vous avez du bois de
disponible mais il y en a pas de temps
que ça par rapport à la demande qui est
croissante
donc est ce qu'on peut nous nous
avantager nous offrir des privilèges
pour qu'on soit tenté d'acheter
québécomm encore faut-il identifier les
produits qui sont québécois et ça c'est
une autre vision sénateurs ça oui si
vous allez dans votre quincaillerie dans
votre centre de rénovation vous allez
voir que le marquage n'est pas une
époque est aussi évident que dans une
épicerie par exemple pour les produits
alimentaires
l'industrie 10 50 % de bois est exportée
faudrait produire plus est-ce que
produire plus de bois sortir plus de
bois de la forêt publique c'est la bonne
chose à faire
la stratégie nationale de production du
bois qui était rendu public quelques
jours avant noël par le ministre du four
ne lit pas on ne fait pas de lien entre
l'augmentation des coupes qu'il que
certains demandent et et la satisfaction
des besoins de l'industrie québécoise de
la construction et de la rénovation
il ya une dizaine d'objectifs et dax
mais y'a rien qui dit on aimerait que
vous favorisez des produits la
fabrication de produits qui répondent à
l'industrie québécoise de la
construction et que vous vous travailler
main dans la main avec les cours à bois
de votre région afin de mettre sur pied
ce qu'on appelle des circuits courts
rien dans la stratégie et vox ce genre
de nouvelles économies et on pense que
le gouvernement du québec qui a démontré
dans d'autres dossiers beaucoup de
nationalisme et il ya lancé lui-même le
fameux panier bleus on a une belle
occasion avec le bois qui est quand même
un des étalons
d'un pur des plus beaux symboles de
notre nation de pouvoir faire un exemple
salut que dans certains pays européens
où on est aussi producteur de bois on va
permettre bien sûr l'exportation mais on
va d'abord s'assurer que certains
besoins essentiels domestiques qui sont
satisfaits ça s'appelle satisfaire le
bien commun mais satisfaire le besoin
domestique avec 1 2 par carte bleue par
exemple à ça pourrait être une solution
est ce que ça pourrait ressembler à
quelque chose comme une forme de
contrôle des volumes contrôle des prix
gestion de l'offre du bois mais je pense
qu'à une mesure à court terme d'urgence
que madame lebaye le conseil du trésor
pourrait proposer puisqu'elle l'a dit
récemment certains médias que si les
prix allaient rester élevée encore
longtemps on allait intervenir donc on
nous on espère qu'elle va donner suite à
sa promesse donc il ya peut être une
mesure d'urgence pour durant la pandémie
pour six mois ou un an pour le post
pandémie aussi pour faire en sorte qu'on
soit tenté de ne pas reporter nos
travaux en raison des prix trop trop
élevé donc il s'agit pas de proposer aux
fabricants de bois des prix moindres
mais simplement de deûle est d'aider le
consommateur et l'entrepreneur à faire
face à ces prix qui sont élevés mais de
façon plus permanente
on pourrait imaginer une forme de
coopérative d'achat où l'ensemble des
cours à bois toute dernière confondues
depuis plusieurs producteurs forestiers
dans les différentes régions pourraient
s'entendre sur de juste prix et fournir
les bonnes quantités des bons matériaux
au bon moment ce n'est pas ce que nous
vivons présentement richard darveau
merci beaucoup pour ces propositions et
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit